Avengers: Endgame provided a defining moment
for Scarlett Johansson's Natasha Romanoff,
AKA Black Widow, one which caused a stir among
many MCU fans.
In an Entertainment Weekly interview, directors
Joe and Anthony Russo felt the need to clarify
their thinking in including the scene, which
one could hardly argue was out of character
for Romanoff.
Be advised that spoilers for Endgame follow.
During the Avengers' "Time Heist," in which
separate teams of heroes were sent to different
periods of time in order to retrieve the six
Infinity Stones long before Thanos could get
his massive purple hands on them, Romanoff
and longtime partner in crime Clint Barton
(AKA Hawkeye, AKA Ronin) are dispatched to
the planet Vormir to secure the Soul Stone.
The pair meet the ghostly Red Skull, who informs
them that they would have to deal with the
same quandary faced by Thanos in Infinity
War: in order to possess the stone, one must
give up that which they love.
Realizing the ramifications of the situation,
the old friends proceed to fight to the death,
that is, for the right to be the one to go
over the cliff, making the ultimate sacrifice
so that the other might complete the mission.
In the end, Romanoff plunges to her doom,
leaving Barton in possession of the stone
and faced with the unenviable task of returning
to the present day to inform the Avengers
that Romanoff was no more.
As New York Times pop culture reporter Kyle
Buchanan noted on Twitter, Vormir's not exactly
a great planet for redheads.
"A soul for a soul."
It was a sacrifice only fitting for a character
who had a lot of red in her ledger, and was
driven by a need to wipe it out, but some
fans saw it as an unfortunate example of "fridging,"
a trope in which a female character's death
is used to drive the motivations of male characters.
The trope gets its name from an issue of Green
Lantern, in which Kyle Rayner literally discovers
his deceased girlfriend stuffed into his refrigerator.
In their interview, the Russos defended their
decision by bringing up multiple points, first
and foremost, the fact that in an all-out
brawl between Black Widow and Hawkeye, the
eventual victor would necessarily be determined
not just by who wanted it the most, but by
who was the most skilled.
Joe Russo explained,
But that was far from the only factor.
In defending their choice, the directors explained
that in essence, Romanoff was motivated by
her desire to see her friend redeem himself
after his stint as the bloodthirsty Ronin,
and reunite with his lost family, who had
all been dusted in the Decimation.
Anthony Russo told EW,
Joe Russo continued to relate that Widow's
choice plays into the larger theme of Endgame,
which is the opposite of that explored in
Infinity War.
The director continued to say that this specific
theme of sacrifice was appropriate to Romanoff's
character arc, going from a mercenary-style
loner to a full-fledged protector who sees
her survival as being secondary to the goal
of the Avengers, the only real family she's
ever known, to save the universe itself from
untold destruction.
It's an idea explored in multiple Marvel Cinematic
Universe offerings, from Steve Rogers' willingness
to face certain death at the conclusion of
Captain America: The First Avenger to Vision's
insistence on sacrificing himself so that
Thanos would be thwarted in his attempt to
possess the Mind Stone in Infinity War.
Black Widow fans always knew she'd go down
fighting, and she did, not against the forces
of evil, but against her most beloved ally,
for the right to be the one to die so that
the other might be able to live in peace for
perhaps the first time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.